[Music]
hey what's up party people welcome to
another episode of honest trailers
commentary commentary commentary today
we're talking about our
wild experimental trailer for every
streaming service oh it's so avant-garde
what are we doing
really pushing the envelope of what an
honest trailer can be
with this one joining me is lon harris
and joe starr
uh thank you guys for being here we're
going to talk about uh our thinking
behind
the house trailer what we really think
about every streaming service if it
wasn't clear from the video
and then afterwards we will respond to
some viewer comments and show you some
deleted scenes and tease you
with next week's honest trailer which is
also going to be a fun one
um also uh i would be remiss if i didn't
tell you about our next fandom 5 trivia
show which is this friday and it's on
the simpsons
the simpsons uh that'll be at 4pm
pacific 7pm eastern so sign up for that
you can win
real money for answering questions about
fake
people um i'm sad i can't enter this
as a as a fandom although would you
tomorrow on sju
like to do a round yeah yeah definitely
okay as long as it's and we should
clarify
is this all the simpsons seasons or is
it like
yeah there are there are these i just
submitted these questions to billy right
before we went live here
uh they are mostly from the golden era
so like
two two through ten two through 12. feel
great about that
i really zeroed in on those there's a
few not a lot of specifics from later
seasons like
okay some stuff that spans the whole
show but when we go specific it's
usually from the peak years that
old folks like you and me in season 25
what is the name of homer's son
yeah i mean i just felt like it would be
crazy to do specific stuff from like the
last
seven or eight years because it doesn't
have that kind of dedicated fan base
anymore
okay thank you lana thank you for not uh
making it impossible
um i actually think as a pretty hardcore
simpsons fan myself that it is
really easy but i actually sent some of
the questions to
other simpsons fans just to kind of get
a better gauge
and they they think it's like right on
so
i think you would i think you and i
would ace okay good we'll find out
tomorrow in sju or whenever we end up
doing that
um but today we're talking about
streaming how do you guys feel about
streaming what is it
what is streaming is it no thanks you
guys you guys try out these streams you
got to stream this you heard about these
streaming services yeah you check i mean
we're old enough
i'll i'll put it this way we're old
enough to remember um
you know cable basic cable uh when your
tv had like
13 buttons on the side and each one was
a channel that kind of thing
um better or worse these days
or what's better and what's worse i mean
look tv is
is better now like i liked tv when i was
growing up but like i think it's hard to
make the case that like the la la
commish era was better than like today
you know like i mean like they're
watchmen and like you know like there's
so much amazing stuff that goes on tv
today that was not even thinkable in the
past
so yes i think in that way streaming is
great but it also feels like we're like
growing pains like they kind of have to
figure out how it's going to really
work and like a lot of the original
ideas that i think a lot of these
companies had were
the wrong ones like we've seen uh just
as a quick example
people love stuff like tubi and
voodoo and like roku channels like i
just want to put something on and leave
it on and that's kind of different from
the netflix like
pay us eight dollars a month and then
binge the crown
sort of model yeah yeah
part of me misses channel surfing but i
also think that that was
nostalgia and if i were to actually do
it i would just be
annoyed and uh and feel bad after it was
done
you do channel surf uh that's kind of
what i was thinking was like
that's all we do now is just endlessly
scroll through netflix
and go i'll add that to my list
that's worse that's a definite downgrade
it's way more fun to channel surf and
then stumble across something
weird on television that you're going to
try out or just like a
fun commercial even than it is to browse
endlessly that's that's the worst thing
of this modern era is just to flip
through
the library but i do feel like there is
a thing
happening now where stuff that people
would never have checked out before is
just like
in front of them and so they'll watch it
and so we're all kind of being exposed
to like
weird other kinds of shows that probably
wouldn't have stopped somebody if they
were channel surfing like
the most recent example i can think of
is that charlie kaufman movie that went
up on netflix it's like this
crazy art film with jesse clemens but
nonetheless had like
millions of people check it out when it
went up because it was on the netflix
front page like
that's just interesting and i don't know
we've seen what final impact that will
have
yeah that's true and i think it's like
there's such a
this is like a real expansionary phase
and it's going to contract although it
already has it's already kind of gone
the number of streaming services has
gone up and down and up and down
yeah but i think like just in absolute
numbers people
on the high end have like 30 bucks a
month that they're willing to spend on
these things
like that's two or three of them and the
rest of them are just going to be sol
like
right in in five years uh would this be
a much shorter trailer
yeah i think i think eventually some of
these are going to start to merge your
your uh well you're i think you're real
low hanging for the stuff that's like in
the starring section of this trailer
is going to go first i think uh
you know your um your crunchy rolls and
you which we forgot in the trailer
um part of hbo max right yeah it kind of
they have a hub that's like selected
stuff from country but it's not the full
crunchyroll catalog yeah but
i think i i think that stuff's going to
be the first to to merge
and then and then i i honestly think uh
yeah you're paramount pluses and your
your your peacock premiums and stuff are
going to start to roll into the giants
into apple
into amazon and netflix i mean there is
that avod
model what they call the advertising
video on demand so stuff like like i
think peacock
is interesting in that you can get a lot
of the peacock shows for free you just
have to watch
ads and 15 million people have already
started watching peacock
so like i think there might be a way
forward there like i think the
i think joe's absolutely right like sign
up for dc
universe and paramount plus and
crunchyroll and v-e-t
plus and disney plus like that model has
its limits people are only gonna pay for
so many of those but i do think
there might be for the stuff that you
aren't willing to pay for but you still
want to check out there might be a road
forward that's like
more like that kind of a service where
you know it's like a roku channel like
all right i'll watch these four snl
sketches and then i'll watch an ad
for my next four snl schedules i think
my my bigger prediction
is that in the next i don't know five
years
i i don't know what the timeline is but
i i think the next like earth-shattering
like
disney-bought fox or disneybot fox and
marvel and star wars or whatever is
going to be apple buying netflix
i think that'll one one one of the ones
that just has an impossible amount of
money probably amazon or apple's gonna
buy netflix and that's gonna
make everybody crap their pants
rightfully so
or like i can see somebody creating a
bundle
of these things um and like finding them
the the struggling ones banding together
and uh
like how hbo max is sort of an umbrella
of different subscriptions even though
it's a partial selection
right you're right back to cable and you
find like one company
if you buy subscribe to this then you
get netflix disney plus and hulu or
whatever which which weirdly i mean not
to take us down a whole different
road here but that opens up its own can
of worms because then you get these
fights over
who controls the data like who gets to
who gets their hands on all that useful
marketing
information because like that's the
situation we have right now with like
peacock and roku where
it took forever for peacock to get on
roku because they both
want to be the one that's selling the
ads and to get
you know all that juicy algorithmic like
who's watching what
and who's going to buy all of this
garnier fructis or whatever they're
trying to sell
you know like and that becomes the the
issue and hbo max
still not available on broken for this
similar kind of reason so
it's all gonna be like we're in a decade
of figuring out how this whole market is
gonna work
who wants that fructis um i know
good smelling shampoo yeah throw it up
there
smell like berries all day why wouldn't
you yeah
anyways it's a long trailer so we might
as well get started with every
streaming service roll it
in a world where no one wants to pay for
cable anymore
a culture will rise where every dumb
media company
thinks you like them enough to become a
paid subscriber but until narrative
media fails completely
and we just stare at each other on
social media all day live through a time
when there's too much to watch
the good stuff is hard to find and
everything is gonna cost you
ah progress every streaming service
remember the company i do think we will
not five years from now but maybe 50
years from now
i think that we will be more likely to
watch uh uh each other all day
than we are to watch anything that was
like written and produced by
a a group of people like i mean so it's
like tick tock
is just gonna be the thing and it'll be
like nine take nine things from
tick tock but i do think that we're just
gonna be like staring at each other
again again different rabbit hole but i
think
um tick tock's already changed
comedy i think music yeah yeah yeah
people already would rather watch um
uh what's up sarah cooper the one that
does the dubs
yeah blair uh what's your name who does
uh the um
just the you know the fake videos of
like i'm this racist governor's wife and
i've got something to say and
yeah uh they're so much more relevant
and funnier
and hitting so much harder than snl or
any of the like
traditional uh like you know com
oh i mean it's already changing i think
in 50 years we will all be
mutants living in a cave somewhere
very true to uh yeah the love could be
drying strips of venison on the freeway
yeah like wow
very very optimistic that we're still
going to have streaming services in 50.
but we will still be manipulating our
devices with our weird club hands
uh to watch uh sarah cooper do trump
dubs i can see that and then being like
yes
get him this is the one that'll bring
him down and i'd leave that
bastard we finally
we broke into the temple and found the
pelosi paw that all
oh good times all right also oh before
we continue
uh kevin man i just want people
as they watch this trailer to appreciate
kevin our editor
yes usually it's easier not that it's
ever easy but it's easier because we're
talking about one movie and he can just
pull the clips from that movie this is
just complete like carte blanche the
script did not have very many
guides on what to do and he brought it
together beautifully and our graphics
uh uh wizard uh robert holtby who who
created some amazing custom stuff for
everything i mean
right it has to like rip off the format
and font and like look of
every streaming service we talked about
yeah also i think
just as a for mulan last week i i think
he hand painted the title
diddy yeah we got an email that was like
hey guys can you submit your fake title
for mulan like a week early because
right and paint the logo and it was like
i actually at first thought like is
there a piece of software called hand
paint
like yeah i figured that was like enough
a software thing yeah you know i think
you can't
change the logo and then ran a camera
oh well okay uh a retrospective props
for that
i need to look at that logo again did he
anyways that's a good anyway sorry
they're they're amazing and i just
wanted to make sure that uh
uh everyone in chat and everything was
sending them some love so yeah
they're great yeah it's like artists
working and then they're like what
should we do next then it's like a bunch
of goof balls in a room like
i got an idea that's ridiculous what a
system
okay keep going remember the company who
used to send you dvds that would sit
unwatched on your coffee table
now they're a streaming service full of
shows that will sit unwatched in their
own library
where the employees and the shows all
get axed after two years
because they're too cheap to give the
cast and crew a pay bomb and too flush
with cash to resist making a new show to
boost signups in outer mongolia
but hey at least they've made some of
your favorites resurrected some dead
movie genres
and handed some great directors a blank
check who cares if they're billions of
dollars in debt
when your company name is a verb the
money printer goes
quickster
[Music]
oh yeah i just uh do you guys remember
quickster i loved quickster
that was insane the the those like
emails that i got like maybe a couple
days apart like
netflix is now quickster and they're
like we are so sorry we are no longer
we apologize for intimating that we were
going to become quickster
what was the idea that like they needed
to like put
the mailing you dvds as its own company
like you're gonna forget that that's
what netflix used to do or something
yeah that was a bad marketing call
uh i was gonna say i i wrote the first
draft of that little run
and i spent we ended up cutting it
anyway but i spent so long thinking
about
what movie because it was like that line
was original egg
remember netflix the company that you
still have their old copy of blank
sitting in the back of your desk drawer
and i like agonized over what would be
the funniest movie to still have
yeah like the net boondock saints like
what would you have rented 15 years ago
and then still left in your desk i'm
trying to think cause like everyone has
that last dvd
that just sat there until they canceled
their account a legends of the fall
perhaps there was one for me yeah
that's an instant watch yeah
yeah i'll get back to you on that maybe
netflix still knows maybe i never turned
it in
i i i think the net was probably the i
think that's the one i actually put in
the draft
the net yeah yeah the issue with this is
um uh
uh we all split this up uh everyone
wrote their own little sections and it
ended up being like 20 pages long so
a lot of things had to get cut down
sorry
anyways let's keep going
from the network that brought you star
trek the twilight zone
and 10 000 shows about crime solving
acronyms
comes a streaming service that's chock
full of exactly that
plus a bunch of shows that were designed
to sell denture cream to viewers who
haven't known how to change the channel
on their tv since 97.
it's a service who's been so fully
ignored by non-trekkies that their
parent company is already changing the
name
good sign too many tracks
get ready i just want to a
shout out to the the people who are in
any way involved with
uh uh but in front of or behind the
camera on any of those
ncis csi shows because they are set
for life oh my god uh yeah it's like
11 seasons each those shows and like
yeah it also feels like and and full
respect like a lot of great actors on
those shows i'm not knocking it but it
does seem like as
acting assignments go you kind of figure
out your mode and then it's just like
just keep just do that forever like
there's there's never
it's that it doesn't those performances
aren't like modulated episode episodes
like stabler is stabler no matter what
that's what you're coming for made by
dick wolf man yeah right like horatio
kane is not going to stop horatio
he's going to take off those sunglasses
i mean there might be new dimensions to
horatio kane
maybe uh yeah maybe even a grisham
crossover but
you're really doing the same thing week
to week and i i really liked the first
csi when it came out i watched csi uh
hell yeah oh yes peterson yeah it was
great yeah it was fantastic
margot
[Music]
mark helgenberger
uh but yeah i could i can't believe that
it can sustain an entire universe but
there you go go for it i'm very happy
for them it
i guess it doesn't lend itself well to
streaming because
cbs all x is not doing so hot people
people don't want that on demand
they want to like tune in on on their tv
every week right i mean i think like
you know in terms of the the big
subscription ones that the the advantage
of a hulu
or a netflix is so huge they've just got
these massive massive libraries of just
like weird
niche nonsense and like old shows and
it's like
really hard for these young upstart ones
to compete on that level like
unless you've got like a huge lineup you
know like because
they do they have some good shows on cbs
all access or like some interesting ones
but
you know how do you fight netflix
they've been doing this for years
there's hundreds of shows come out like
it seems like every month well i wonder
too if cbs
if this is going to help cbs sort of
realize that part of the success of
these shows is that
everyone's parents turn on cbs in the
morning
and then just leave it on yeah yeah and
that that is part of the idea of taking
the
going from the brand cbs to like all
viacom under paramount oh yeah because
they're gonna start throwing comedy
central stuff and nickelodeon stuff and
mtv stuff
and it'll start to feel more you know
broad soon like spongebob is all going
to go there and whatever look if i can
stream
uh the head from liquid television
um i'm in if i can watch every rock and
jock
game oh yeah you know what would be
really valuable
actually is if they took if they could
get the music rights to all the old
beavis and butt heads because you
haven't been able to watch the music
videos in a long time like yeah
the animated shorts are everywhere but
the them talking over the music videos
is like only on youtube now
same with the old uh same with the state
like when they really
stopped all the songs were gone when
michael ian black goes to buy
pants i need to hear the breeders
cannonball gotta hear ken
otherwise it doesn't work
good song all right anyways let's keep
going music rights are tricky
let's listen to khan get ready for nbc
universal's rushed late entry into the
streaming race
which was supposed to make its big debut
with the tokyo olympics but instead
limped out with a socially distanced 30
rock reunion special promoting their
other shows
do you know how many amazing shows i
have on peacock alone
that's a deal breaker ladies still you
see alex
you also get ads sure
who already tried this model and it
failed but did they have a in their
name
i think i mean not
have cocked from the impossible
just the hubris of uh of nbc thinking
people
really knew it as the peacock well yeah
even
even realize that nbc original logo is
supposed to be a peacock
honestly yeah it was like it clicked
when they said it like oh yeah that is
kind of like a peacock's feathers but i
thought it was half a simon game
half a simon that would have been a
better
streaming server's name is half simon
half simon plus
yeah i guess this is why they just go
with the most boring plus thing because
uh everything else is either taken or
stupid
or if you call it nbc none of the nbc
shows you like are on it
right i think that's why they had to
avoid nbc because you think nbc you're
like oh i'm going to go watch friends
inside films like
that yeah what a bummer names are hard i
don't they do
they do have all of parks and rec on uh
peacock now which i have been enjoying
they got frasier
yeah great wings you can watch the full
run of wings that's true
when you're when your centerpiece shows
are 30 rock
reunion specials wings and frasier
you're in trouble from the get-go
that 30 rock reunion special was dire
and i love 30 rock i was really excited
but yeah you'd think that like any show
like them would be up to the moment of
doing like a meta
uh isn't it this weird that we're all
here
it seems perfect yeah it's also like
they didn't let them do a 30 rock they
they had to do the 30 rock sketch for
the up fronts
basically it was such a bad call to like
launch on the back of that dumb thing
instead of like
something and and like a brave new world
attitude like way to get americans
excited well this is something else we
cut that should be in the deleted scenes
that was about all the uk
stuff that it's all british that they're
rebranding as originals and a lot of a
lot of these places do that like a lot
of the hulu originals and stuff like
that like
letter kenny it's called a hulu original
but like it's a
show that aired in canada and then they
just bought it yeah
um i guess a little behind-the-scenes
magic
we were gonna do this earlier in the
summer
uh when everything was originally
scheduled to drop but then a couple of
the streaming services kept pushing
right
because um i think they were just hoping
that all of this was going to end and
they could launch with the olympics so
uh yeah so i think nbc was the holdout
and we kept
sort of like pushing this back into
right yeah peacock was the one we were
waiting on
yeah because nbc every year gets the you
know they do the olympics broadcast so
their idea was well
all the time on tv they'll be like and
go to peacock for more
and then if you were on peacock it would
just be like here's you know you missed
uh
this swim race here it is you know like
and that was their plan
and then it was like ah no there's no
olympics ever again
sorry uh too bad they just had to like
innovate and they just didn't do a great
job of coming up with like the next day
it's sort of like hbo max 2 where they
were gonna launch with like
we got all six friends and we put them
in central perk
stare at them and now they can't that's
the future of entertainment that's what
i'm telling you like just like human
aquariums
i mean that brad pitt and jennifer
anderson like reading the script of
fast times was like the most viral clip
of last week so yeah
right yeah at a certain point all pop
culture will devour itself in this kind
of ready player one
conflagration and all that will be left
is uh
is the bodies anyways let's keep
watching
in the body suits that interact from the
people who brought you everything in
your apartment
comes the only service in the streaming
wars who's listening to everything
you're doing
alexa let's chat i really hope that
triggers who brings you edgy acclaimed
programs
amount of absolute crap and free two-day
shipping courtesy of a modern-day feudal
peasant
but don't worry they're working on
turning them into delivery drones which
are just a turret gun away
from becoming murder drones i feel like
bezos is the only one taking the
streaming wars literally
[Laughter]
[Music]
cyber dying
love youtube yeah amazon's such a weird
it's so weird um that they're in the
business that they're in
like it doesn't seem to like the
business of amazon
is so complicated or multifaceted
because it's like their business is like
selling server space like that's where
they make most of their money is like
web servers and then like as an
afterthought they're
uh putting every store out of business
and as an afterthought to that they're
like
saving like indie film it's like i think
that's the
weird goal is like the server space
is the foundation and then i think he
honestly just wants to kill everything
it's at diapers.com story where he was
like screw you diapers.com i'll just
sell diapers dirt cheap until you die
i think that's what he so he's just like
i'm gonna save indie film until indie
film dies
everywhere else i mean that's what's
fascinating is all these other companies
we're talking about like this is all
they're trying to do like we just have
to we gotta
look guys we got a streaming service we
gotta come up with one we gotta compete
with netflix
for for amazon and bezos it's literally
just the marketing like he just wants
you to sign up for prime
so you give him his hundred dollars a
year or whatever and then he can send
you like every time you need batteries
or a lighter
he can just ship that to you that's the
goal it has nothing to do with like
maybe a new season of the expanse that's
just like how can i get you dumb dumbs
to give me this money every year for the
shipping
and then i'll throw in utopia and
flynn's new thing yeah and then i think
there's a decent chance
that he's also hoping you'll like a show
enough
that once everyone's morality catches up
with them and we're like hey
maybe we can just have our stuff in five
days so that people can have pee breaks
he'll be like but if we do that you
don't get the expanse but i can't miss a
meal of time
hold on hold your bladder i gotta see
wheel of time season four so send me
they keep sending me the batteries yeah
it's so true yeah i think amazon and
apple is also like they're in the
business of selling you
uh dongles or whatever uh right well
apple it's like
they wanted to you know like still steve
jobs is weird thing of it's all gonna be
like you gotta be here with us the whole
time like walled garden like don't ever
leave
apple's ecosystem so it's part of that
like they want you to use your apple tv
and your apple remote and your apple
device to watch
apple shows and then hbo max is like
their division of
t like they just want to sell cable uh
internet subscriptions to you so
we're in this weird historical moment
where nobody
needs to care about what they're making
which is viacom they're like
i'm still like look at this we got a
movie studio the weird move to me is we
used to make booze
i think i don't know we're just french
or something the weird move to me and i
think we'll see it happen
at some point is like when at t like
buys walmart
and then it's just like yes like we sell
you jeans
we sell you shows and like that's their
big somehow
amazon competition and that's just when
we start to go full weyland yutani
yeah i mean it's um it's it's horrific
in the uh effect it has on everybody's
live sense that six companies are gonna
own everything
but uh it's freeing at this at this
particular time artistically because
they don't care what they put on there
they're i think for better and worse
because sometimes they could use some
more tlc but they are handing these
creators
money to just be like just make
something just give us hours of
stuff that we can put on our service and
just say that oh there are
truly bonkers things that somehow get
through
and made on these services you're like
how like
what was this meeting like how did he do
this
it is a glo it's a
massive version of you know we we sort
of like
we always talk about like the thing that
quibby was good for was
in the early days they were just giving
everyone shows and lots of our friends
were
paying their rent because quibby was
like what do you want to do you want to
do a craft show about
uh making dolls out of recycled
flat sure yeah yeah mrs maisel is
obsessed with her golden arm
here okay but it's like that on like
this global scale
it's like the the you know the steak
potatoes days of defy when they were
just like what does smosh want to do
sneeze for 15 minutes okay here's five
million dollars
yeah um hey that that video clicked well
joe
[Laughter]
uh but it's like that yeah it's like
that with like a-list directors who are
just like i don't know
apple's letting me do whatever i want
you know yeah there's a netflix two and
a half hour movie that this japanese
like auteur experimental filmmaker sion
sono did called the forest of love
it's like about this con artist and
serial killer and then
not only did they let him make a two and
a half hour movie but then they let him
expand it into a mini series
funding this wild days i mean it's great
for me but like what's wrong with you
i mean they handed ryan murphy 300
million dollars to just
uh uh uh produce mad libs oh my god have
you guys seen ratchet have you watched
ratchet no
it's it's your insane bonkers it's pure
and sad it's
pretty like after i tried hollywood it's
like i just think his uh
stuff is not for me this is like it's
supposed to be a cuckoo's nest pretty
cool but it's like
hannibal like it's just crazy so weird
yeah
uh anyway all right anyway yeah they're
all cashing in
yeah get that money let's keep going
love youtube but hate how free it is
like reno 9-1-1 but wish there was less
of it then come on over to quibby
where you can watch new originals or
just wait until they're ruthlessly
mocked on twitter
like lady in love with her golden arm
you've got to take off that prosthetic
no i can't take off my golden arm
ever or third wave feminist sex doll
road trip
fp anxiety can you like
but what quibby lacks in content it also
lacks in anyone willing to pay for this
there isn't even any joy in this it's
like making fun of a sick dog
i hope someone takes quibby out for one
last run around the park before it's too
late
you're a good boy queebs okay maybe not
good but
okay you're an okay boy
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah there's not much to add to that
like we've we
were only adding to the pylon of quibby
but i think that the reason that
i feel okay with the pylon in this case
is the is the hubris again of jeffrey
katzberg and
uh what's in him meg which whitman yeah
uh of
uh just being like no we get it we know
what kids want to do
they want uh to pay for the things they
already do but worse
like just the way they host everybody uh
is is why everyone's relishing um
their downfall it's honestly astounding
how much
2020 quibby is like 2010 youtube like
it's all the content is so
like every single one of their
unscripted series could have been a
buzzfeed video
in like 2011. like the same exact
concept
and execution like it's like they didn't
ever watch youtube and realize like oh
this has been free on the internet for
like a decade we should probably not
charge for it i'm just glad that uh
phantom didn't receive an rfp
from quibby this morning with
it's golden armies we still might uh
yeah we still might um
uh i will say reno 9-1-1 it's
funny it's very funny even in small
little doses
uh they're great it's a sketch show why
wouldn't this that i think that's great
uh i wouldn't pay however much a month
to watch just that but
uh if you like rio 911 they're the
gang's all back together but also if you
ever
if you ever wanted to understand like
just how much money
billionaires have if i
tanked a project and lost a thousand
dollars i'd be
screwed they're losing
billions and they're just like meh
you know they're not their own money
yeah you know jeffrey katzenberg's gonna
like bounce back this isn't the end for
him
it'll be fine yeah it's absolutely
insane
if you watch that uh that howard ashman
documentary that's on disney plus which
i highly recommend it's great there's a
there's a scene where
uh menken and ashman pitch aladdin like
front to back like with songs
to jeffrey katzenberg they're like and
then it's gonna be prince ali and he's
gonna sing this song and then i'm gonna
go to the genie
and it's like done and you're like that
was amazing and he's like no
and he just sends them to go work on
beauty and the beast like that should
have been the end of your career what
are you doing
who rejects aladdin oh
wow like imagine those guys singing you
a whole new world and you're like
meh next can i watch it on a
phone in 10 minutes can you flip it
vertically and it'll still look good
no get out of my office does the genie
have a golden arm
well you know what he made shrek so he's
uh he's still good in my book
without katzenberg there'd be no he
wouldn't there'd be no all-star
shrek we've talked about this yeah
whatever
move on move on donkey and without meg
whitman
we wouldn't have i don't know wasn't she
a republican
governor or something yeah it wouldn't
have her failed gubernatorial campaign
wouldn't have all that good yahoo
content
all right let's keep going hey you
yeah you who needs an all new service we
know why we're both here together
you don't want another new show to watch
you want to watch a show talk about that
show
i do i'm sorry guilty as charged then
maybe leave a naughty little comment
down below
go ahead say whatever you want does
netflix let you do that
call us a bunch of sims it only boosts
our engagement metrics
now let's get wild and see where the
recommended videos take us ooh
a flat earth essay you always know what
the dumbest
worst people are looking for america's
saddest home videos
i mean i don't have much to add to that
that's youtube
watching people talk about things that
you watch somewhere else
yeah um or like 5 a.m wife prank
[Laughter]
i just really want to see you know ben
shapiro destroy
some colors or yeah sjw distortive facts
and logic
yeah we bought a ghost on the dark web
blank movie was a complete cinematic
failure
yeah they accidentally joined nexium
yeah logan paul fights who it'll
surprise you
um that's it that's uh those are all of
them
and us good good for us still sticking
with it
yeah all right keep going do you like
friends
you better because showing the reruns
cost about half a billion dollars
so give some money to the service that
still has all the great hbo shows
the best of adults win and a huge chunk
of the criterion collection
but it's all being subsidized by the
dollars who want to watch this for the
900th time
how you doing
it's funny because it's wait why is it
funny
friends with benefits remember regular t
i think that hbo max is my personal
favorite
streaming service so much good stuff
yeah i just watched the parallax view
last night ah yeah
in terms of movies like it's a much
higher like they don't have as many
movies as netflix or amazon but it's a
much higher caliber like a lot more
classic movies and movies you
want to re-watch like i'm pretty
confident i could find something i want
to watch
on there at any point whereas i don't
feel that way about
uh any of the other ones otherwise
they're killing it too
right i was gonna say i don't swim
they've really they've really started to
beef out the
the adult swim library and those back
libraries until like now you can watch c
lab or space ghost
or i think aquatine is coming soon like
the app itself feels really buggy
oh yeah yeah it's kind of crazy which is
frustrating uh but
i think once they get that sort of
figured out um
speaking of their adult swim hub y'all
watch this tig tone
y'all seen that no you should watch it
it uh i watched the first two and they
they've stayed in my brain they're real
weird and screwed up
and is that the fantasy one it's like a
parody of like high fantasy
stuff yeah it's really nuts uh that's
the best adult swim that's what it does
straight
rain i am wearing a victorville film
archive shirt i'm not sure if speaking
of it
i don't even know if i like those on
cinema at the cinema
oh my god yeah i don't know if i liked
it but it
sorry tom's thinking about it oh tom
goes to the mayor yes
yes a 12 ounce mouse i was re-watching
some 12-ounce mouse the other night it's
great that's that's great i like that
that
like library they need to draw adventure
brothers yeah
i think that's like later this year
early 2021 that's moving over but yes
that's coming
the only perplexing thing to me is uh
and i'm assuming this is coming too
is um this cinemax has like a bunch of
really good
critically acclaimed shows and they are
under the att
warner brothers hub and right now
there's no
uh plans to put those on hbo max and i i
just feel like
no one can make anything new right now
and you have like 10 shows that could be
runaway hits
i feel like they're gonna do it's like
one of the dc universe things where they
like they know that cinemax at some
point is gonna get
folded in and it's just like they have
to figure that timeline out first before
they announce
when the shows are gonna move over but
yeah like banshee and warrior and like
those shows are definitely coming to hbo
max at some point the red shoe diaries
well that's what i was going to say they
need to do the horny 90s
hbo hub on hbo max which is just red
shoe and taxi cab and real
madrid actually brand it skin yeah i
didn't realize they made eight poison
ivy's wow
yeah look just wow i'm kidding i just
said you go on skin imagine
well i kept making it i think they did
but like shutter has joe bobby
she's four like uh shutter has joe bob
briggs hosting horror shows
like pay shannon tweed some money and
just have her like curate
stickers that'd be hilarious yes that's
awesome that's a great idea
all right we're giving giving away too
much good stuff for free let's let's
keep watching
that's what we do remember regular tv
shows
who remembers go green for the service
that acts as a life raft for all the
rapidly drowning cable channels
plus originals that target the women who
are going through a lot right now
demographic
with flexible options like paying to
just watch hulu paying to watch hulu
without ads
paying to watch hulu and live tv or
paying to watch hulu in live tv
with premium add-ons okay we're just
back to being cable again aren't we
i see your game hulu disney minus
experience a higher count i don't really
know what's going on with hulu it seems
like it's
like i don't think disney really knows
what they're doing with it
either it got a lot better recently
because of the fx
on hulu yeah like now that all the fx
content is done being just on
fx.com and has moved over to hulu it's
like astronomically better even like
fargo is premiering
next week and it'll be on on
and it's going to be on hulu the day
after it's on fx instead of having to
wait like months to catch up with it
so like that's that's awesome like and
stuff like devs going right onto hulu
like that made hulu
that like doubled ooh's value overnight
unless you're just like really into the
mass singer and you want to watch it
yeah i do think that you're right the
the
mass singer and i do think like they're
the ads we've all seen like they have
sports which is a
huge deal uh um for a tv service like
that's
the only reason people hang on to cable
so if you're
if you're looking to cut the court this
is the one but yeah i just don't see it
like
i don't see why disney would want to
keep it around because like
well it's because it doesn't really have
a clear brand and they don't really
control everything so it's like
just kind of a dumping ground well it's
because they don't want to put more
adult stuff on disney plus because the
disney plus brand is like kids kids
families and they don't want to put
anything on there but it's got like an f
word or whatever so something like woke
the new one with lamorn
morris it's like uh it's a little too
grown up for disney plus so that's why
that's what
that's what job hulu is filling right
now yeah moving forward i don't i don't
know if that'll always be its role but
that's certainly its role
in this moment the important thing is
that that's where you can watch penn 15.
oh good show yes except right another
great example of like a great original
show that wouldn't fit
anywhere else disney streaming yeah all
right
uh cool let's keep going yes
experience a higher caliber of
programming crafted to meet the precise
standards of the company behind the
thunderbolt to usb
dongle the lighting to headphone jack
adapter
and a thousand dollar stick featuring
storytelling so refined and exclusive
nobody you know has ever seen or talked
about it you can't tell me blind aquaman
viking show and the office where michael
gets me too to reel
this has to be part of some kind of
elaborate tax game or something
i pass once upon a time
lon i know you've seen them but you have
to right for the newsletter i
i write a newsletter about streaming
shows so i did buy
you know i got a couple months of apple
plus and i watched a bunch
servant the one that m night shyamalan
produces is legitimately really good
i really like that show i recommend it
it's creepy
it's weird it's got um lauren ambrose
from six feet under and toby kevill
from like he's like the evil gorilla or
whatever in the
the plan of the apes movies like that
one's really good everything else is
like
weird and like interesting but i don't
know if i would say good
the blind jason mamoa adventure show is
insane
like yeah it's the is the always sunny
uh gaming
show any good question it's funny i mean
it's it's like very much like
workplace comedy but with you know
gaming like obviously written by people
who know that world and like gaming
tropes and whatever and it's like a
pretty good send up of
you know gaming culture right now uh f
marie abraham is
amazing he's like the creed like he just
pops in to say like three crazy things
per episode and then leaves
and it's amazing he's the best part of
the whole show i just do think that uh
more so we've been talking about this
earlier but more so than any of them
apple
just has too much money on hand that
they don't really know what to do with
so they're like let's just make
let's make shows sure that's like a
decimal error on our balance sheet yeah
i think the worrying part was when some
of the creators started being like
yes we get notes from apple executives
who are like hey
maybe the show should do this and like
some of them and some of them it does
kind of feel that way like they're just
decisions and choices that like
i don't feel like this is where it
originally went like this feels very odd
to me
and so yeah like that's that's an issue
like how is that not going to be
oh i can totally see like uh current
apple executives being like uh you'll
take this note
we invented pixar and someone be like
well you didn't invent pixar and they're
like
it got invented next door i'm on the
same campus yeah i can see uh apple
getting a little
could the blind dystopian residents
discuss the use of a ucb
c
how much more convenient that is it
really help us with our q3 roll out
yeah well uh they could do whatever they
want i haven't seen uh
any of it um anyways let's keep going
once upon a time
a magical company was drunk with power
dominating the movie theaters
cruise lines and the happiest place on
earth for kids
and weird adults with too much time and
money but then a play
took all the revenue streams away and
put all the pressure on the little
streaming service that could
but with the help of a few great shows a
vault full of nostalgia
and literally nothing else of value you
just might forget to unsubscribe long
enough for the mcu stuff to come out
the mickey mouse hub starring
these other streaming services we didn't
have time to mention
too spooky for me crackle still around
good for you crackle sports without the
actual games
games without the actual games regular
stv all over again
only fans what what's that one
i don't recognize that one guy sorry and
yeah i don't know where you guys are
even getting these from
i have never heard of them personally
that's for sure every streaming service
look at that it looks so good let's just
pray these places never catch on that
we're all sharing the same account log
in
and yeah props to uh uh giving each of
us our own unique little icon which we
had no input in but i i think they did a
good job without us
very very well done yeah he's pretty
solid
you're like some type of uh you're a
sword
i'm just where like people are like
that's a happy face but it's actually
something serious
um uh yeah i don't know whose sword that
is somebody let us know in the comments
what am i the bad guy from polar express
that's what we call you when you're not
around damn it
well you know spencer he's being a real
bad guy from the world
your count olaf from lemony snicket
that's that's that's
nph as the evil uncle from lemony
snicket series of unfortunate events
careful don't look don't try to look too
closely at this tiny image that's on
your screen
we're all going to look like josh gad on
those reunion shows where he's just
always like this
hey do you guys like the goonies
how are you going to say josh gad in um
god you said lemony snicket artemis fowl
[Laughter]
what accent is he doing no one no one
knows no it's no one that's true
all bananas all right this is a long one
so let's uh if there's
time uh uh let's do some deleted scenes
if we got them queued up actually loads
of things that i auditioned for at the
beginning of the year
and didn't get any of them i had that
moment of oh my god
and then just thought everything in its
right time flicks a lot of people kind
of uh
will come at daisy
in the sequel she's not the greatest
actress that we had in the sequel
trilogy which i could kind of understand
i had the same thought like am i doing
this but no i'm not
just roll through it molten if you ever
start watching browsers while we're live
we're
yeah we're screwed we're really scared
man
well what's that i've never heard of
that before
by the way some all-time great reads
from john on that starring
yes yes
flickster netflix debt finance and chill
must see tv somewhere else
[Music]
billions and billions and billions
short-sighted queefy
useless
the one with sports doo doo
k boo
and that's it all right well there i did
i know for a fact
we had the the uk uh uh shows all coming
to peacock and it was really funny
because everything was so british on
there
yeah i i wrote i wrote one run that we
didn't end up producing and i get it
because it would have been a huge pain
in the ass but it made
it made me laugh to put together was all
the netflix shows that are like
strong independent lady detectives
investigating like an over-the-top
murder from all around the world
because like they've made one of those
shows from literally every country
right they do the things yeah reality
shows used to do or still do that where
it's like if a format works
yeah you air in the us or in australia
they make a different version for every
region and netflix does the same thing
with show concepts just
died or her marriage just fell apart or
her husband died 10 years ago
and there's like a cold case that she's
got to go like there's just like so many
of that one kind of show from every
european and south american country
yeah hey when the template works you
know yeah
all right let's uh let's fire off a few
fan questions uh
not over stair welcome but uh adam
holbert writes where did the sexy voice
idea
come from uh joe that was that was yours
right that was mine
uh i kept i don't know i took like four
i sent you like all four
i think i took like four cracks at the
youtube
thing and they were both they were all
pretty much saying the same thing like
the joke was you don't want to watch the
witcher you want to watch
an easter egg video about the witcher or
guy reacts to the witcher
and they just weren't funny and uh
and then i i just like the idea of
youtube seducing you into being a
horrible person
it's also nice to like just change it up
because these can be a little bit yeah
they can be really uh so having a
different tone
um for some uh arceus lord of creation
rights eventually it will all just be
screen junkies plus
whereas brent dreyer writes just wait
until screen junkies deluxe launches
wow oh i like that sounds like a lot of
work for
us
[Laughter]
[Music]
a lot more like recommend this movie or
that movie in this other studio
yeah that sounds like one of those moves
where they're like uh
guys we got a great idea it's called
screen junkies deluxe and here's what we
want it to be and we go
can more people help and they go no oh
do it
but kevin smith is going to unbox things
guys
tiffany sandmeyer writes walmart's
voodoo didn't even make an honorable
mention i think it was in that grid of
regular ass tv
yeah last week unless i think it was
maybe i think toby got in and
you didn't but pretty much the same
thing yeah i think the big ones we made
also pluto i think also walmart sold
voodoo
probably because it's not a very
christian name yeah uh-uh mexican food
no voodoo in that house yeah uh and then
finally practice santorini
let's end on a a tie-in uh question
uh this is for lawn about the phantom
five is the simpsons movie fair game
this is miss orsa asking
you know what uh i don't know if there
are any questions about
it that made the final cut but yeah i
think so i mean i think if we touched on
it
that would be fair it's part of
simpson's lore
okay cool well there you go uh so check
that out phantom five
uh this friday 4 p.m pacific 7 p.m
eastern you'll be asked questions about
largely the golden age of the simpsons
and maybe something about the movie and
maybe some about
the new stuff smattering of earlier or
later stuff
but mostly a light smattering yeah no um
tracy allman show well maybe we'll see
no no no no
all right that's our show for uh uh for
today come back next week where we'll be
talking about next week's honest trailer
which is something that um you know
will uh uh make the sky look pretty at
night if you go out on the last day of
summer today you might go outside and
see something pretty that'll give you a
clue into next week's honest trailer
uh at least i think that's next week i'm
not even sure i know what this is hang
on
yeah no no that works you'll see you'll
come back next week and you'll all see
thank you lon thank you just very poetic
buddy yeah
[Music]
you